The Joe Rogan experience, but jock valet,
you have been studying this most of your life too long, too long.
We, we discussed it last night at dinner that your interest in this came
from an experience that you actually had as a child. You actually saw a UFO.
As a, as a teenager with two other witnesses. Uh,
one of the witnesses was half a mile away with binoculars.
So I'm pretty sure that, um,
that that object was real and it was a classic disk middle of
the afternoon clear sky,
absolutely clear at the time I became convinced that it might be
a prototype of something that would be coming out later. And, uh,
you know,
we're here many years later and we still don't have anything like that.
It was just hovering and it was fair.
And you've been studying this for so long.
And this was something you guys talked about in the film that you were actually
the character that the French UFO researcher and close encounters of the first
kind of the third kind rather was modeled after the Steven Spielberg films.
Yeah. Ellberg was intrigued with the idea of,
of a character that was not quite as weird as, you know,
the ETS, but it was a lot weirder than, you know, the,
the people on the ground in the U S trying to make sense of this and the
military and so on. So he needed this intermediate character. He felt,
you know, Frenchman was, was the right thing to do.
And so did you talk to him about the film? Did you talk to him about when,
when he was putting it together and.
Uh, I, a
journalist put us together when about halfway through the, you know, the,
the final, final shooting of the film, and there were,
there were gaps in the movie at that point. And we, uh,
so we had lunch twice together and, uh, it was, was a lot of fun.
He was at the time he was looking for a transition between the
time when they, they know that, you know, the big thing is coming,
the mother ship is coming and they don't know where,
and the mothership is sending signals,
but they can't decipher the signals. And I, he said, you know,
he had spent the morning at the jet propulsion laboratory and he said,
he couldn't make any sense of all the mathematics they had.
And I said, well, maybe you get to have, you know,
two screens that give you an angle.
And the angle tells you where the thing is. And he said, no,
that's too complicated, you know, and takes too long. Right.
It got to be just a few minutes in the film.
And then I thought of a photograph that was on the desk of Dr. Hynek,
you know, Dr. Jane Hynek,
who was the air force consultant on UFO's at the time.
And I was working with him building databases and so on and
on that photograph, there were three guys, you know,
really well-dressed on ladders, around a huge,
um, sphere of the earth in the lobby of some buildings,
somewhere with pieces of string that they were,
they were putting the string over the earth.
And I told Dr. Heinrick. I said, you know,
what's the story behind this? And, and he said, well, the,
when the first Sputnik was launched, you know, October 57,
nobody had a computer program to compute an orbit,
but they knew where the Sputnik had been seen.
Nobody expected the Russians to come up with this,
and they needed to know where it was going next. So they,
the New York times called the director of Harvard observatory
saying, um, can you give us a comment on the Russian satellite?
And the guy said, Hey, it's three o'clock in the morning. You know what,
Russian satellite. And so they got dressed in a hurry and they,
they were trying to compute the orbit by putting a string around the,
uh, around the model of the earth, in the lobby of the, of Harvard.
And I thought it was so funny and, and Spielberg said, that's it, you know,
that said, the general says, come on. Uh, you know, you know, the,
the geographer who is, uh,
the interpreter of the French of a French guy, uh, says, well,
it looks like it's somewhere in Wyoming, you know, but where in Wyoming,
you know, where should we go? And the, the general says, you mean,
we've got $10 billion worth of radar and cameras and everything
else. Nobody's got a map of Wyoming and they break into the lobby of the
building next door. And they come back with this globe and, you know,
they've got the globe and they, they look at it,
look at it and get they're called in eights. And because the, the,
it turns out the geography, it tells them, you know, those signals,
they look like a longitudinal attitudes. So they, they, they, you know,
they, they get the point where it's going to be and that's,
that was a piece that was missing in, in the movie.
So that was really proud of that. You know, it was, it was really fun. Well,
so it's the, one's funny part in the movie.
It's a great movie. And it's a,
it is probably the movie that got me most excited about UFO's when I was a kid.
And I remember thinking if you have folks were coming here from another planet,
one thing that I remember thinking is why would they even bother talking to the
government? Like what, what do they care who the government is? Like, if,
if I was looking at an ant colony, um, I'm not going to ask the ant colony,
which one's the, the elected official that's in charge of all the other ants.
You don't give a. You're just like trying to study the ants.
And I felt like if something was coming here from another planet that was so
sophisticated,
it could either travel from another or travel from another galaxy.
Why would it care like who the president is or who the generals are?
You know, not only that, but the witnesses don't talk to the government either.
You know, by now the witnesses are tired of being ridiculed by scientists
and, you know, by and told that those things don't exist. So they don't,
they don't talk. So they'll talk to, you know, uh, people like you,
people like me, uh, because I trust, you know, they, they trust me.
And in Silicon Valley, you know,
you wouldn't believe the number of people who come to me, you know,
including CEOs of companies that I've worked with would tell me about sightings
that people in their family have had or sightings they had, including,
you know, sightings in Vietnam, for example.
And so on when they were in the military that have never been reported.
And the government isn't getting that.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free, only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.